a la brasileña juliana y sus niñas
visitan un piso en muñana donde viven
solo 200 habitantes
conrado les acompaña es el presidente de
la fundación madrina una asociación que
ayuda a las familias vulnerables a la
que bonita
hace 10 años el esposo de juliana tuvo
que huir brasil después ser herido por
disparos en españa' encontraron trabajo
y formaron una familia nunca necesité
pedir ayuda nunca necesiten así porque
teníamos el detenida su trabajo y le
cobraba muy bien y yo igual pero con la
crisis los dos han sido despedidos ahora
toman el riesgo de marcharse de madrid e
ir a un pueblo donde el alquiler será
más barato
pagamos setecientos euros de alquiler y
estábamos cobrando muy poco entre luz
gas agua y todo lo demás no alcanzábamos
esperan encontrar trabajo en el campo o
en los comercios locales como ellos
miles de latinos han empezado así a
repoblar el campo en españa' 3.500
pueblos la mitad de los municipios se
están vaciando en esas zonas el estado
pide un mínimo de niños para mantener
las escuelas
la llegada de las hijas de juliana es un
alivio en muñana nos quitaron una unidad
de educación infantil porque bajó
muchísimo la matrícula en infantil
entonces bueno si vamos si la vamos a
aumentar pues también depende entiendes
de que nos abran más clases más aulas y
el número de profesores también tendrá
que aumentar con la fundación madrina
conrado propone a familias en situación
de precariedad de viviendas baratas en
zonas despobladas desde enero hemos
alojado 300 familias tenemos una lista
de espera de 500 familias y los latinos
serán aproximadamente un 50% esas
familias quieren huir las urbes donde es
difícil vivir desde la pandemia en
madrid la fundación madrina también se
ocupa de colas del hambre cada vez más
largas entre ellas las familias latinas
son mayoritarias tenemos colombianas
peruanas
brasileñas de república dominicana de
todas las nacionalidades a una parte de
ellas les gustaría instalarse al medio
rural si tengo una vivienda y un trabajo
pues me iré a un pueblo a vivir ahí
y puedes estar mejor que estar aquí en
la ciudad y sin trabajo y sin
y poder tener un poco de enero para mi
paladar de mi bebé desde la ciudad de
valladolid la confederación de centros
de desarrollo rural promueve la venida
de inmigrantes a las zonas vaciadas en
su plataforma pueden encontrar ofertas
de trabajos y de negocios
estos iconos no que aparecen pues
representan algunas de las ofertas que
estamos haciendo a todas las personas
que quieran ir a vivir algún pueblo la
confederación ya ha ayudado a cientos de
familias latinoamericanas es muy
positivo que muchas personas inmigrantes
se puedan ubicar además teniendo en
cuenta que hay trabajos agrarios
ganaderos importantes en el medio rural
que muchas veces la población de este
país de españa no quiere realizarlos ya
no gracias a la confederación esa
familia de uruguayos justamente encontró
una casa y un trabajo hace un año
quieres jugo de melocotón juanjo se
trabaja todos los días cuidando a un
hombre mayor me siento útil
por lo menos no estoy en mi casa
y no pienso otras cosas ojalá que siga
así por mucho tiempo
después de muchas mudanzas miguel ha
podido por fin centrarse en el instituto
mackaine al estar fijo para los estudios
es mejor porque si no me tengo que mover
ya las cosas no son las mismas y todo y
al ser así el polvo pues también ayuda
claro que él justo enfrente de la casa
se acaba de mudar una familia de
peruanos han podido venir gracias a un
sistema propuesto por el ayuntamiento
que hacemos una bonificación de 100
euros por niño en el colegio hasta un
máximo de 300 euros que es más o menos
el alquiler son unos 330 aproximadamente
con la llegada de familias el pueblo ha
podido salvar a su colegio el alcalde
espera ahora obtener mejores transportes
infraestructuras un ejemplo que se
podría multiplicar por todas las fallas